-How are you?
-Oh, delightful.
-Yes. You often are.
-Yes. Really, it's just a joy.
Every day. Every day.
[ Laughter ]
-A lot of people have
asked -- asked me,
and I'm sure, in turn,
they've asked you,
"Is Donald Trump good
for comedy?"
What is your take on that?
-Well, I mean, I moved here --
pbht! -- 40 years ago?
-Uh-huh.
-He was --
He lived, like, over there
-Yeah.
-I've been around him 40 years
And I said,
from the very beginning,
before even he was nominated
and people started
asking that question.
And I feel the same way today.
He's good for comedy in the wa
that a stroke is good for a nap.
[ Laughter ]
-About right.
That sounds about right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You -- Your show, though,
which I was surprised
when I saw the title,
"It Gets Better Every Day" -
-So was I.
-Yeah.
Because you're not known
for your optimism.
And it's a
very optimistic title.
-Well, it is.
I thought maybe
if I put it out there,
it would change things.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Bl-bl-bl, no.
[ Laughter ]
It's -- You know, it's the thing
that I do, you know they -
I do a lot of interviews,
you know, when you do a tour
And they call up and every tim
they say, "How you doing?"
And every time, I say, "Oh
it gets better every day."
And if they -- If they think
I'm serious,
I know it's not gonna be
a good interview.
-[ Chuckling ] Right.
-So, you know --
and I just think there are
things that we -- we do have
that we can be thankful for.
-Sure.
A lot of -- A lot of folks
out there
are worried about global warming
and climate change,
the end of the world
as we know it.
And they worry about this
because they listen to --
well, let's face it --
scientists.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And 96% of them actually
believe that it's --
it's not good.
I know this because
I have to do research now.
-[ Chuckling ] Yeah.
-You know, you have to
research this stuff.
And I didn't get into comedy
to do research!
[ Laughter ]
Okay?
I got into comedy
to make stuff up!
[ Laughter ]
So they -- The reason that the
feel this, the scientists,
is because they gather
something -- data.
-Yeah.
-A lot of people
don't know this,
but data are actually facts!
[ Laughter ]
And so, when you listen
to that stuff, it gets --
pbht -- that can ruin a day.
-[ Laughing ] Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
So what we decided to do,
as a people,
was to turn over the whole
dealing with climate chang
and global warming,
and we handed
that responsibility over
to people who never passed
a science class.
[ Light laughter ]
[ Laughs ]
That they didn't get that,
scares the [Bleep] out of me
[ Laughter ]
And -- And -- And so they --
these people,
they instinctively --
they don't use this --
they instinctively feel
that we've got
nothing to worry about.
-Yeah.
-So I feel better already.
[ Laughter ]
-You -- I have to ask you this
as far as optimism.
First, I want to
give my condolences.
Your father passed away,
but 101 years old.
-Yeah.
-And your mother
just turned 101 years old.
-Yes.
-Do you feel fortunate?
Yeah, absolutely.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Do you feel fortunate
to have genes like that?
-Well, I feel there's a
possibility it's not genetic
I think I may be a reptile
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
At that age,
there's a chance, sure.
-Yeah, my mother, when
I called her in her mid-90s,
and I said, "What's it lik
living this long?"
she said -- and I'm quoting --
"I wouldn't call it living."
[ Light laughter ]
"I'd call it not dying.
I'd call it overtime."
[ Laughter ]
We celebrated
her 100th birthday,
and she blew out the candles
and said, "Nobody
should live this long!"
[ Laughter ]
And at 101, she -- she said --
she blew out the candles
and she said,
"I've made it to 101!
Now I can drop dead!"
[ Light laughter ]
And then
we sang "Happy Birthday."
[ Laughter ]
-We were talking backstage
You have a very unique thing
you've been doing at your shows.
You've been livestreaming th
last 20 minutes of your shows...
-Yes.
-In a segment you call
"The Rant is Due."
-Yes.
-And this is not
20 minutes of your rants.
These are rants
that other people,
people in the audience,
have written for you.
-Yes, and they -- the audience
that comes to the show
writes things
about their town,
or, if you give them too lon
and they're sitting there
and watching each other,
they start to say things
about each other
that are very nasty.
-Yes.
-"Why is that idiot --
That jackass
is wearing an idiotic hat.
Why am I always stuck behind
a person who's 7 feet tall?"
-[ Chuckling ] Right.
-And then -- And then
a lot of people write in
much longer rants
about -- about the town
that I'm in
or the state that I'm in
or the area.
And it really is a show
that is really a show like..
Let's say, I'll be
in Rochester, Minnesota,
this week.
And they -- It will be the
Rochester, Minnesota, show
-And so you -- And when
do you collect them?
Is it at the end of the show
or...
-No, they come in --
Literally, I get them --
They come in the room
and they start --
we start getting their --
the things beforehand.
And then they can go
to my website and they can -
-So, ahead of time?
-Ahead of time.
The longer ones
come in ahead of time.
-That's great.
-People seem to know.
And then it's livestreamed
throughout the world.
So I've got people --
I have fans in Tanzania.
[ Light laughter ]
-"We want to hear you
complain about
Rochester, Minnesota."
-Exactly.
-[ Laughs ]
-And it makes them feel better
about Tanzania.
[ Laughter ]
-What a service
you're providing.
Hey, thank you so much
for being here.
It's always such a pleasure.
-It was great. Thanks so much.
-Lewis Black, everybody!